To wrap up, today we learned about not only that the world is becoming parallel but why.
The GPU is a processor that takes advantage of some of the most important technical trends in computing.
We looked at our first CUDA program,
learned how it worked, and changed the program to do something new.
Now for our first project, we're going to use CUDA to input a color image,
and output that image in grayscale.
This will involve a map operation over every pixel in the image,
where the operation on each pixel is converting the input color
in red, green, and blue to a single intensity value.
When you're done, you'll have the chance to show your grandparents
what your new photos would've looked like back in the day, or at least that's what I'm going to do.
Enjoy the assignment, and I hope you enjoy an excellent presentation from Dave for Unit 2.